y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se encontraba saturada por sentir
demasiado y el mismo lo contó en un
documental de científica titulados
todos en algún momento nos saturan por
sentir demasiado determinadas distancias
dolor sufrimiento y hasta tías pero no
me refiero al alanís es una de las 1500
millones de personas aproximadamente en
el mundo y según los científicos nace
con mujer que predispone tubos de
maniobra sensorial para que sea más
sensible que al resto
percibe y siente más que los demás
y nos ponemos a pensar en este número
tan alto y abarca aproximadamente el 20
por ciento de la población mundial para
que nos hagamos una idea es algo así
como 34 veces la población de argentina
nuestro país ahora quién es de diferente
este grupo de personas percibir y sentir
más que los demás y sin ser más que
perciben más las ardillas y las
tristezas
los placeres no se limitan sólo a las
emociones también persiguen más al tacto
el roce de la ropa de los calzados los
olores los sabores también tienen mucha
más sensibilidad auditiva y visual y
esperen porque eso no es todo también
perciben sienten que les afecta
muchísimo las emociones del otro
pueden percibir sus labios pueden
percibir mil objetos
viven penetrados constantemente de
emociones intensas las 24 horas del día
y quizás ustedes me suelo imaginar lo
natural
no se preocupe no estamos hablando de
ninguna experiencia paranormal
esto es biológico y científicos de
diferentes partes del mundo lo has
investigado llegando a una misma
conclusión
y estas personas
no tiene ni una enfermedad ni un
trastorno desde el premio a la década de
los noventas
han estudiado a este grupo de personas y
descubrieron que su amígdala cerebral
específicamente su ínsula tiene una
actividad el resto
ahora bien si nosotros trasladamos esos
estudios a este auditorio de
aproximadamente 100 personas
entonces en este momento deberían haber
alrededor de 20
con su sistema neurosensorial están
persiguiendo
y sintiendo simultáneamente más que la
red
quizás todo lo que escribía
anteriormente es lo que te pasa a vos
o tal vez lo que conté es con lo que
ustedes se siente identificado puede ser
que la persona aquí está centrada en
lado cuyo
en la que también sienta que esto es lo
que está pasando en este momento
bueno le quiero contar en todo
y lo descubrí hace aproximadamente tres
años luego de luchar toda una vida
contra lo que para las personas que me
rodeaban era un exceso de sensibilidad y
la misma palabra no es sinónimo de
fortaleza cuantas veces quizás desde
chicos nos enseñaron que si sentimos
demasiado tratemos de no demostrarlo de
guardarlo para nosotros
y me quedó muy grabado a fuego una frase
de
y no te afecte tanto
como si de esa manera iba a tener el
camino hacia el éxito y haga levantar
pero porque me cuento todo esto porque
si te pasa lo mismo que me pasa a mí
desde muy chica no soy un pintor barroco
no son de otro planeta son lo que hasta
ahora se conoce una persona más
una persona con alta sensibilidad
y si no te pasa nada de lo que acabo de
contar también te va a servir todo lo
que vamos a decir a continuación porque
debido al alto porcentaje de personas
que tienen este rasgo que son personas
con alta sensibilidad durante toda tu
vida vas a tener que relacionarte o
tratar con entre 400 a 1000 d
la pregunta es cómo
si soy o estoy con una persona más
bueno tenemos muchas características
pero hay cuatro bajos están
interrelacionados y que sobresale se
manifiestan de forma conjunta y esto es
muy importante aclararlo no se dan de
manera aislada y 6 voy a contar de qué
se trata pero antes me gustaría que
observen con detenimiento la ciencia
imagen
quisiera que se traslade a este momento
de su vida él transmite de imagen
la buscaría que piensen en la emoción
que les evoca
de algunas sonrisas
porque claro quizás nos traslada a esa
época de lalín y es un momento mágico
cuando salían a disfrutar junto a su
familia de este tipo de espectáculos
bueno justamente eso era lo que querían
mis papás para mí que cada vez que he
dado el circo a mi ciudad al igual que
los demás niños vamos a asistir a mi
familia y disfrutar
pero bueno llevarle en diferentes etapas
de mi vida voy a contar por qué
me llevaron sola con algunos familiares
que eran muy allegados amigos y es más
hasta incluso descuentos una vez
organizaron una comitiva de parientes
para que me acompañen y me contacten el
entusiasmo
el tiempo el resultado siempre fue en un
mar de lágrimas que nadie nadie
comprendía
y claro porque la libra de los 80 no
había mucha conciencia sobre el mal
implicaba
pero aquí cinco años cuando mis lágrimas
si tenían una razón de ser
y la respuesta a la pregunta de por qué
lloras siempre fue por los animales y
con este ejemplo que me parece muy
gráfico es que quiero explicarles estos
cuatro rasgos principales que nos
atraviesan toda la vida y de esta manera
podemos entrenarlos quizás un poquito
más
uno de ellos es que procesamos la
información de manera muy profunda así
que quizás para los demás niños ir a ir
a un espectáculo y disfrutar del show
con piletas de animales y era algo lindo
y gracioso para mí desde la gira de
ingreso al circo era ver jaulas con
animales que no eran de mi entorno por
lo tanto eran animales y fueron traídos
de otros lugares que estaban solos sin
su familia en una jaula diminuta que
salían solamente para realizar sus shows
sin importar en creencias del tiempo
y además estos animales me imaginaba
vivían y viajaban así como llegaron a la
ciudad a muchas otras ciudades sólo para
dar un show
mi sistema empezó a ponerse en alerta
y no termina ahí porque vamos a escribir
un segundo lo que tenemos y es que nos
sobre estímulo más quizás duran más que
el resto de la población y claro a todo
esto que se había procesado se sumaba el
hecho de que escuchaba el ruido de un
látigo para que los animales ejecuten un
truco veía un aro encendido o fuego para
que tengan que atravesamos cuando era
algo
y no hay nada de eso cientos de personas
mirando y aplaudiendo algo que para mí
era totalmente injusto
aquí los dominador de la tercera
característica y en que percibimos
utiliza que para el resto de la
población puede pasar desapercibida así
que yo podría percibir cuando los
animales estaban temblando de miedo
antes de hacer un truco para que les
haga bien también persigue a la atención
en las miradas y en los cuerpos de las
personas que tenían que hacer que este
truco se ejecute para cambiar
esencia de suspiros y el nervio que
había en torno a mí
y bueno quiere decir de nuestro cuarto
rasgo tenemos neuronas espejo muy
activas así que somos altamente
empáticos
así que todo lo que les conté se sumaba
el hecho de que lo podía percibir a
estos animales esté sufriendo y que todo
lo que querían es aparecer como un show
de felicidad no lo era en realidad por
todo esto que en el momento que el circo
no era un lugar mágico y disfrutable mis
papás no se preocupen lo entendieron
después de llevarme varias veces no me
llevaron más también era cool para tener
una niña declarando durante toda la
función así que ellos la hicieron no
estoy solo está disfrutando
joselyn de tanto pero a mí sí me dio la
frase de que cuando uno que sí se hace
más fuerte
antes de descubrir debajo lo que hice
fue quiere poner las pruebas y así
nuevamente a uno de estos espectáculos
el resultado fue exactamente
mi alta sensibilidad no se fue y me va a
acompañar toda la vida así que para
aquellas personas que nos piden que sean
menos sensibles lamento decirles que no
es más estoy convencida que si no entra
la sensibilidad de respetarse y
escucharse más tendríamos un mundo mucho
menos dañina
ahora bien
no son todas lágrimas y sufrimiento con
las injusticias recuerdan los 4 a bajos
que dije que estaban interrelacionados
que significa que no importa el orden
siempre se van a dar en las personas que
tienen alta sensibilidad y también nos
convierten en un valor agregado para el
resto de la sociedad esa es mi amiga y
les voy a contar por qué porque como les
dije no sobre estimulamos estas gramos
fácilmente pero saben cuál es la razón
porque recibimos 10 veces más
información que el resto de la población
y no solo las recibimos las recibimos en
detalle porque percibimos las iglesias
ahora bien con toda esa información que
hacemos la procesamos profundamente por
lo tanto muchas de las vivencias tener
información que recaudamos que somos muy
pequeños quedan grabadas a fuego en
nosotros y son muy útiles porque sabemos
cómo y cuándo utilizar
pero no esto también hagas como le dije
hay un cuarto largo que tenemos y es
información y su caudal del salvaje que
nos acompaña siempre no es ahora para
nosotros
como conectamos muchísimo con la gente y
sus sentimientos vemos cuál es la mejor
manera de ayudarlos y de usar ese
potencial que tenemos
mi pregunta para ustedes
cualidades una mamá y un papá
un compañero de trabajo
profundidad
su jefe que pediste tener una pareja
quizás la tienen ya no sé
en ustedes quizás en el balance
y de todo lo que conté las personas que
tienen sensibilidad genética son una
ventaja una desventaja o si son por
decirlo así alguien que como persona que
puede acompañar al resto de la población
de una manera positiva para finalizar
les cuento algo camino ayudarlas
un sismógrafo es altamente sensible
percibe los movimientos y registra cada
movimiento de las llamas en muchísimas
vivenciales y más desde esta y percibe
terremotos que ningún ser humano puede
sentir
ha sido un sismógrafo es altamente
sensible y en un alto registro
las personas con alta sensibilidad
también lo tenemos de manera emocional
incluso nadie negaría que un sismógrafo
es sufrir
la división no sirve para nada es una
molestia
recuerda bueno y ya durante toda su vida
muchas emociones como a las personas
y la convirtió en canciones que fueron
sumamente exitosas
todos nosotros vivimos rodeados de niños
adolescentes y adultos que tienen el
mismo registro emocional son
poderosamente sensibles por favor no
desaprovechemos su potencial
[Aplausos]